-Okay, Seth, welcome back.
This is the moment of truth.
You're known
for doing many voices.
You're also an amazing singer.
So I wanted to put that
to the test
and play a little game called
"One Song, Many Artists."
The way it works is,
we're gonna pick a song.
You'll start singing.
I'll hold up a name.
You'll sing it in that voice,
and then as the song goes on,
I'll pick up a different name,
and you'll change your voice
and sing it as that person.
Is that okay?
-That sounds good to me, man.
-The song you'll be singing is
"You're Nobody
Till Somebody Loves You."
Roll it.
[ "You're Nobody Till
Somebody Loves You" plays ]
-♪ You're nobody ♪
♪ Until somebody loves you ♪
♪ Well, you're nobody ♪
♪ Until somebody cares ♪
♪ Well, you may be king ♪
♪ And you may possess
all the world and its gold ♪
♪ But gold won't bring you
happiness ♪
♪ When you're growing old ♪
♪ The world still is the same ♪
♪ You'll never change it ♪
♪ Just as sure
as the stars shine above ♪
♪ Well, you're nobody ♪
♪ Nobody till somebody
loves you ♪
♪ So find yourself
somebody to love ♪
♪ Diggity ♪
♪ The world still is the same ♪
♪ You'll never change it ♪
♪ Just as sure
as the stars shine above ♪
♪ Well, you're nobody ♪
♪ Until somebody loves you ♪
♪ So find yourself somebody ♪
♪ Find yourself
somebody to love ♪
-[ Laughs ]
Come on!
That is how you do it
right there.
Seth MacFarlane, oh, my gosh.
Dude, I can't wait
to see you again in person.
Thank you for doing this for us.
I appreciate it.
Congrats on everything.
And, yeah, we'll be watching you
on the Peacock, bud.
-You bet, man.
My pleasure.